THIS IS "THE FIVE."
PRESIDENT TRUMP THREATENING BOLD
NEW ACTION IN THE FIGHT OVER
BORDER SECURITY.
TRUMP SAYING THAT HE WILL SHUT
DOWN THE SOUTHERN BORDER AMONG
WARNINGS OF IMMIGRANTS
OVERWHELMING THE SYSTEM.
THE PRESIDENT CUTTING FOREIGN
AIDS TO THREE CENTRAL AMERICAN
COUNTRIES, THIS COMES AS BORDER
PATROL AGENTS EXPECT TO SEE OVER
100,000 APPREHENSIONS THE
SITUATION IS AT A BREAKING POINT
AND THAT HE HAS NEVER SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE THIS BEFORE.
HOMELAND SECURITY SECRETARY
KIRSTJEN NIELSEN ANNOUNCING
SHE'S ORDERING HUNDREDS OF
ADDITIONAL AGENTS OF THE BORDER.
THIS LATEST POTENTIAL MOVE I
PRESIDENT TRUMP IGNITING FIERCE
DEBATE FROM BOTH SIDES.
>> IT ISN'T A BLUFF.
YOU CAN TAKE THE PRESIDENT
SERIOUSLY.
>> AND THE PRESIDENT SAYS HE'S
GOING TO CLOSE THE BORDER,
THAT'S A TOTALLY UNREALISTIC
BOAST ON HIS PART.
>> DEMOCRATS WILL NOT GIVE US
ADDITIONAL MONEY OR ADDITIONAL
PEOPLE.
THEY WILL NOT CHANGE THE LAW
ACTING AS THIS GIANT MAGNET FOR
PEOPLE FROM CENTRAL AND
SOUTH AMERICA.
>> WE ARE GOING TO DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO STOP IT.
>> YOU HAVE THE MEXICAN
GOVERNMENT ALLOWING THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE ALLOWING TO WALK ALL
ACROSS MEXICO.
THEY PROVIDE THEM BOSSES AND
DROP THEM OFF AT THE BORDER AND
SAY HERE.
>> Dana: PETE, WE HAVE A
SERIOUS PROBLEM.
YOU HAVE THE SECRETARY SAYING WE
CAN'T GUARANTEE I CAN PROTECT
THE COUNTRY.
I CAN'T GUARANTEE WAS COMING IN.
YOU HAVE BORDER PATROL GUYS
SAYING THEY'VE NEVER SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE IT.
IT'S A CRY FOR HELP.
WASHINGTON IS WHERE THE PROBLEM
COULD BE SOLVED BUT THEY ARE
THROWING UP THEIR HANDS.
>> Pete: INCLUDING FORMER
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS
LIKE JEH JOHNSON COMING OUT AND
SAYING IT IS IN CRISIS.
1,000 TODAY WHEN I WAS DHS
SECRETARY WOULD'VE BEEN A BAD
DAY.
NOW WE HAVE 4,000 A DAY.
>> Dana: EVEN BERNIE SANDERS
DID CALL IT A CRISIS.
>> Pete: THEY CALL IT A
DIFFERENT KIND OF CRISIS.
THEY DON'T SEE IT AS A LAW AND
ORDER CRISIS.
THEY DON'T SEE IT AS A
REFLECTION OF THE FACT THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS SERIOUS ABOUT THE
PROBLEM AND CONGRESS NEVER HAS
BEEN.
WHY DO WE KEEP TRYING TO DO
THINGS THAT DON'T WORK?
AID TO GUATEMALA, EL SALVADOR,
HONDURAS.
THE LEADERS OF THOSE COUNTRIES
ARE HELPING FACILITATE THEIR
CITIZENS LEAVING THOSE COUNTRIES
TO MEXICO TO OUR COUNTRY.
WE SPEND BILLIONS OVER YEARS
TRYING TO FIX THEIR GOVERNMENTAL
STRUCTURES AND THEIR ECONOMY SO
WE DON'T HAVE THIS PROBLEM.
AT WHAT POINT DO YOU SAY THIS
AID ISN'T WORKING?
>> Dana: JUAN, TWO OF THOSE
GOVERNMENTS ARE CENTER RIGHT AND
SUPPORTIVE OF THE UNITED STATES.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT CUTTING
OFF AID?
>> Juan: IT WILL BACKFIRE
TREMENDOUSLY.
LOOK AT THE PERCENTAGE OF WHERE
THE MONEY GOES.
IT'S LIKE 40% OF THE MONEY GOES
TO ECONOMIC AID TO TRY TO
STABILIZE AND HELP THOSE
ECONOMIES GROW SO PEOPLE CAN
HAVE JOBS THERE.
MORE THAN HALF THE MONEY GOES TO
EITHER LAW ENFORCEMENT OR CRIME
SUPPRESSION.
DEALING WITH GANGS AND THE LIKE.
THAT MAKES PEOPLE FEEL SAFER,
LESS VIOLENT, LESS LIKELY TO
DECIDE IT'S WORTH THEIR TIME TO
ENTER THE UNITED STATES.
>> Dana: BUT THEY ARE LEAVING
IN DROVES.
>> Juan: DANA IS HERE.
SHE'S MADE THIS POINT
REPEATEDLY.
WE NEED TO INVEST IN THOSE
COUNTRIES SUBSTANTIALLY AS A
FIRST STEP TO STOP PEOPLE FROM
MAKING THAT TRIP.
I WOULD SAY THIS.
I DON'T THINK CLOSING THE BORDER
IS GOING TO HELP US IF THE
PROBLEM IS THE HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS.
I THINK MORE PEOPLE WILL COME TO
THE BORDER IF THEY SAY THE
BORDERS BEING CLOSED.
IT'S CLOSED.
THEN YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
DETAIN MORE PEOPLE AND WE KNOW
THE PROBLEM HERE, THIS IS WHAT
PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT, PETE,
IS THAT WE DON'T HAVE THE
FACILITIES ARE THE STAFF TO DEAL
WITH THIS.
>> Pete: BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS
DON'T WANT TO FUND IT.
>> Juan: THEY WANT TO FUND IT
BUT THEY DON'T WANT TO PLAY WHAT
HAS BEEN DONALD TRUMP'S CRUEL
POLICY OF HIS FAMILY SEPARATION.
>> Lisa: I THINK WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS DOING IS
TRYING TO PUT AS MUCH PRESSURE
ON CONGRESS TO DO SOMETHING
BECAUSE THERE ARE EASY SOLUTIONS
TO TRY TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM
WITH THIS INFLUX OF CENTRAL
AMERICAN SEEKING ASYLUM IN THE
COUNTRY.
YOU CAN DO THINGS LIKE THE
FLORA'S DEGREE, CLOSE LOOPHOLES
LIKE THE ONE IN THE 2018 HUMAN
TRAFFIC LAW THAT DIFFERENTIATES
THE WAY YOU TREAT
CENTRAL AMERICAN UNACCOMPANIED M
CENTRAL AMERICAN UNACCOMPANIED N
CENTRAL AMERICAN UNACCOMPANIED R
CENTRAL AMERICAN UNACCOMPANIED S
CENTRAL AMERICAN UNACCOMPANIED V
CENTRAL AMERICAN UNACCOMPANIED R
CENTRAL AMERICAN UNACCOMPANIED U
CENTRAL AMERICAN UNACCOMPANIED S
THOSE COMING FROM MEXICO.
THERE IS THE ASYLUM.
THE DISCONNECT BETWEEN THE
PEOPLE WHO PASS THE SCREENING
BUT LIKE 9% THINK IT GRANTED
ASYLUM IN THE COURTS.
INSTEAD CONGRESS IS MAKING THE
PROBLEM WORSE.
WE SEE IT WITH THE CONFEREE
SOLUTION FOR DHS FUNDING.
ESSENTIALLY HE HAD DEMOCRATS
TRYING TO REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
I.C.E. DETENTION BEDS, TYING THE
HAND OF PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
FUNDING FOR THE WALL AND EVEN
THINGS LIKE SECTION TO DO FOR
WHICH ESSENTIALLY GIVES
DEPORTATION IMMUNITY TO
POTENTIAL SPONSORS WITH
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS.
INSTEAD OF HELPING THE
SITUATION, CONGRESS HAS MADE IT
WORSE.
>> Dana: THAT IS SOMETIMES THE
WAY IT WORKS.
>> Tyrus: CONGRESS MAKING IT
WORSE?
>> Dana: AT THE BORDER --
>> Tyrus: FINANCIALLY IT'S
DANGEROUS.
THERE'S A CRISIS WITHIN A CRISIS
AND WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH BORDER
PATROL AGENTS TO COVER IT, SO
WHAT WE ARE DOING IS TAKING THEM
AWAY FROM SEA AND AIRPORTS AND
ITS LEADING US VULNERABLE.
I WAS DOING SOME INVESTIGATING
AND THE HIRING PROCESS IS BROKEN
TO GET THESE BORDER PATROL
AGENTS OUT THERE.
NINE OUT OF 10 APPLICANTS FAIL A
POLYGRAPH.
VETERANS A LOT OF TIMES ARE
TURNED AWAY BECAUSE ONE OF THOSE
QUESTIONS, HAVE YOU EVER KILLED
ANYONE?
SOMEONE IN COMBAT IS
AUTOMATICALLY DISQUALIFIED.
>> Dana: IS THAT RIGHT?
>> Tyrus: ACCORDING TO MY
SOURCE.
THAT'S WILD.
>> Dana: WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO LOOK INTO IT.
>> Dana: HAVE HEARD THE MORALE
FOR THE PEOPLE THAT ARE THERE IS
REALLY LOW.
>> Tyrus: THEY ARE EXHAUSTED.
THERE IS RUMORS THAT THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN PAID BACK HOURS.
THERE'S A CRISIS WITHIN A
CRISIS.
CONGRESS HAS TO DO A LOT OF
THINGS.
THEY HAVE TO FIX THE VISA
LOOPHOLES BECAUSE MOST ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS -- THEY ARE COMING
OVER LEGALLY BUT THEY ARE NOT
GOING BACK.
ON TOP OF ALL THAT, DEALING WITH
THE STUFF ON THE BORDERS, LET'S
NOT FORGET THE FARMERS, THE
FLOODS.
WE HAVE CRISES NOW THAT WE DON'T
NEED ARGUING AND POLITICS.
>> Dana: THAT MONEY IS BEING
VOTED ON TODAY.
>> Juan: GOING BACK TO WHERE
YOU STARTED, TYRUS, ECONOMICALLY
WHAT AN IMPACT THIS IS GOING TO
HAVE ON COMMERCE.
THIRD-LARGEST TRADING PARTNERS
MEXICO.
>> Pete: WHY ARE WE WORRIED
ABOUT MEXICO?
AMERICANS' JOBS ARE BEING TAKEN
AWAY.
>> Juan: IT'S GOING TO HURT
AMERICAN JOBS.
IT'S GOING TO HURT AMERICAN
JOBS.
PEOPLE WILL BE PUT OUT OF WORK.
YOU'RE GOING TO LOSE IN TERMS OF
SKYROCKETING PRICES ON CARS,
ALCOHOL, PRODUCE.
PEOPLE SAYING THAT IN THREE
WEEKS WERE NOT GOING TO HAVE
AVOCADOS.
>> Dana: IT'S A BIG DECISION
AND IT'S NOT WITHOUT
CONSEQUENCES.
>> Lisa: THIS IS THE
FRUSTRATION OF PRESIDENT TRUMP
BECAUSE WHEN PEOPLE ARE
ACKNOWLEDGING NOW THERE IS A
CRISIS ON THE SEVEN BORDER, JEH
JOHNSON --
>> Dana: WE HAVE THAT, DO YOU
MIND IF I PLAY THAT?
WE HAVE SOUND FROM FORMER DHS
SECRETARY JEH JOHNSON.
>> BY ANYONE'S DEFINITION, BY
ANYONE'S MEASURE, RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE A CRISIS AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
THERE WERE 4,000 APPREHENSIONS
IN ONE DAY ALONE THIS PAST WEEK.
ON PACE FOR 100,000 TO
APPREHENSIONS ON OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
THAT IS BY FAR A GREATER NUMBER
THAN ANYTHING I SAW ON MY WATCH
IN MY YEARS AS SECRETARY OF
HOMELAND SECURITY.
>> Lisa: IT -- HEARING FROM
THE GUY HIMSELF.
THE FACT THAT HE IS ENTERING THE
FRAY AND GOING ON TV AND TALKING
ABOUT THE CRISIS, ACKNOWLEDGMENT
OF THE FACT THERE'S A LOT GOING
ON AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER THAT
WE NEED TO BE PAYING ATTENTION
TO.
IT LENDS CREDIBILITY BECAUSE THE
LEFT AND THE MEDIA CANNOT SAY
IT'S MANUFACTURED CRISIS FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP WITH HIM
WEIGHING IN.
>> Juan: IT'S NOT AN INVASION.
>> Pete: IT SURE IS.
>> Dana: I THINK 100,000
PEOPLE A MONTH IS A LOT.
>> Tyrus: I HATE THE WORD
INVASION.
>> Juan: WE ARE AT A LOW POINT
-- GOAT >> Pete: THEY OUR LAWS
LAWS.
GANG VIOLENCE, DRUG VIOLENCE,
HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
COME TO OUR COUNTRY ILLEGALLY.
>> Dana: ONE OF THE BEST WAYS
TO DEAL WITH IT WOULD BE THE
ASYLUM LAW.
>> Juan: MOST OF THESE PEOPLE
ARE FAMILIES AND CHILDREN
APPLYING FOR ASYLUM.
>> Dana: ONE OF THE THINGS AND
CONGRESS COULD FIX THIS BY THE
END OF THE WEEK, THE ASYLUM LOS
LOSS.
FIX IT AND DEAL WITH THESE OTHER